Hey, welcome everybody
in yet another jam session
for the functional programming 101x
course.
In this one we're going to
do a quick run
over Facebook's extensions to PHP
called Hack. Hack
really is, one way to look at it, its
PHP
with optional typing just like in Dart
and then there's some quite
interesting
additional features that we have seen in
C sharp
and in Dart as well such as
asynchronous functions and iterators.
The additions
that Hack brings to PHP are
optional static typing
here you can specify the
types
and the other thing is
lambda expressions. We will
walk through some examples there as
well.
The examples will all be taken here from
the Hack
website. And I
invite you to have a look at it
and install Hack
on your computer if you're a PHP
programmer.
I think this is definitely a step
up. let's look first
at the
way
you use anonymous functions in PHP
In PHP, maybe I can make this
a little bit larger to make it better
readable.
In PHP, like in C++.
C++
has lambdas as well. When you
capture variables from the outer scope
you have to explicitly use them.
For example here,
there's a variable dollar x here.
In PHP variables
always have this dollar sign in
front so we have a variable $x
that's initialized to bar and here's an
anonymous function that we return.
The syntax is similar to Javascript where you
have to write function,
parameters, curly open, body, return.
That's already rather verbose, but the
the thing here's that
you always have to say which
variables from the outer scope you're
using.
When you want to write
code in a higher-order style using
filter and map, those functions
that we have seen
in the Haskell course. The syntax here
becomes very very heavyweight.
There's more noise
then really what you gain.
One of the
very nice things in Hack is that Hack
supports lambda expressions which makes
the use of anonymous functions in PHP
much more concise. Let's look at
the example here:
here we have
a function that captures b
from the outer scope. So that's used b
here,
but we don't have to say any use here.
And also this syntax is much more
concise
we can just say dollar a, that's the
parameter,
arrow and then triple arrow and the
website
here gives a very interesting
explanation of why
that syntax was used not single arrow or
single double arrow. But here you see
that we don't have to write
all this
noise, we don't have to write functions
we don't have to write
'use' and now suddenly writing
higher-order functions like map,
filter, fold becomes rather
easy. That's
a quite nice thing.
Let's look at some other features of
Hack that we have seen in Haskell.
Type aliases we have seen type aliases
also
in Scala and Haskell if you want to give
a name
a different name to some type you just
define a
type alias and in Hack
you can do that here and there are
also newtype that's the same
concept
as in Haskell and so on.
Hack has a number of ways to define
type aliases and there you see here
there's
OCaml is mentioned.
Interestingly the Hack compiler itself is
written in OCaml.
That's an example of a
very large piece of software written in
a functional language,
that is used at a major internet company.
Many of the
ideas in Hack have been
influenced by the OCaml language.
There you see another example where a
functional language
OCaml is both used in the
implementation
of this PHP
derivative but also the design
of Hack has been influenced by
a functional language, by OCaml.
That's very nice
we've seen lambda expressions, here are
generators and in C sharp there's
yield return.
We've seen those in Dart as well with
the sync* methods.
JavaScript, ECMAScript 6 will also
support
yield and PHP
already
supports generators here. You can
write inside the function body, you
can
use yield and then the result of this
will be an iterable.
The nice thing about this is that if
you use these
iterators and I haven't shown them
in C sharp, in C sharp
I've shown only the linq
comprehensions.
But with iterators its kind of the
imperative
equivalent of comprehensions because
sometimes
you want to generate a collection
but you want to maintain some state and
you want to use regular control flow
like try catch and for loops and
while loops and in that case the
iterators
or generators as they're sometimes called
are super convenient because
it just allows you to write the same
code that you write in normal
function bodies but now you can
temporarily suspend the function body
when you want to yield a
value and then when the consumer calls
moveNext
execution continues here.
The other thing that
is in Hack, that is
quite nice and that's also in C sharp
and as we've seen also in dart are
asynchronous functions,
if you define a function and you say that
it's
asynchronous then inside that function
you can call await on another
asynchronous function
and this asynchronous function
returns an
Awaitable of some value.
An awaitable say roughly is
what corresponds to a task in C sharp
or a Future in Java
or a Future in Dart and
so this await takes on the right hand
side
a awaitable of T and then
turns that into a T.
Under the covers the compiler will
create
a state machine that will take the
continuation
of this program here, so the
rest of the computation it's basically
what's highlighted here and pass that as
the callback
when that awaitable has terminated.
I think
that's about it for Hack.
If you go to the Hack website
it has fantastic documentation
there's a lot of samples, tutorials
and there's also
instructions how to install it on
your own computer.
If you are a PHP programmer and
you're interested in using a much more
functional programming style I would
definitely
advice you
to give Hack a try and as I
mentioned
the Hack compiler is written in OCaml.
And so the influences of functional
programming here
are very apparent, which is always
beautiful. Thank you very much and
happy hacking.